ils ont été convoqués bien avant le
lever du soleil avec leurs valises
cartons sacs de toile et autres paquets
qui déborde du matériel qui reste de
leur vie d'exilé ces réfugiés rentrent
chez eux en série le retour est
orchestrée par la sûreté générale du
liban en vertu d'une entente avec le
gouvernement syrien
pour être admissible au retour les
syriens doivent avoir soumis le nom de
chacun des membres de la famille qui
sont ensuite acheminés à damas c'est la
syrie qui décide qui peut revenir au
pays
une des conditions de retour affirmé son
allégeance au gouvernement de bachar al
assad
accompagné de ses petits-enfants et de
ses filles naïm al masri repart après
avoir passé six ans au liban
les hommes de la famille e reste
derrière peu importe la distance par
courrier le temps un pays a toujours
demande qui dit elle elle espère y
retrouver un minimum pour vivre avec
dignité
malgré tout ce que la guerre a anéanti
allaoui lui est fatigué après toutes ces
années à vivoter
il croit que l'avenir de ses enfants
tous nés au liban pendant la guerre
souffle aînés sera plus clément chez lui
[Musique]
avec une famille c'est devenu très
difficile les conditions de vie en
particulier dit-il
je ne trouve que parfois du travail
journalier j'arrive à peine à gagner de
quoi vivre dans un pays même si nous
devons manger du sable ce sera mieux
je ne peux pas refuser de partir après
tout nord il faudrait bien tous c'est la
deuxième fois que le gouvernement
libanais le gouvernement syrien organise
ce retour des réfugiés vers la syrie
aujourd'hui ce sont 480 av entrer dans
leur pays d'origine depuis le début de
ce programme il ya quelques semaines
maintenant
selon la sûreté générale du liban ils
seraient près de 6000 avoir fait ce
choix de rentrer dans une série toujours
en guerre
pour ces deux copains ce choix veut
aussi dire qu'ils se retrouveront sans
doute bien vite sur les lignes de front
dans les rangs de l'armée syrienne faire
son service militaire est aussi une des
conditions pour avoir le droit de
rentrer en syrie
le gouvernement a promis de pardonner
aux retardataires s'ils reviennent
j'aurais dû faire mon service militaire
il ya un an
alors je vais mettre mes papiers en
règle et le faire dit il il croit que ça
vaut quand même mieux que la difficulté
de vivre au liban qu au delà de la
grande pauvreté c'est la discrimination
est ce qu'il décrit comme du harcèlement
des autorités libanaises que hussein ne
peut plus supporter on peut pas circuler
librement on est contrôlé arrêté et mis
en prison pour trois jours c'est comme
ça sans arrêt pour moi depuis quelques
années ici le président du liban michel
aoun insiste régulièrement pour que les
réfugiés syriens rentrer chez eux
peu importe les développements
politiques et militaires mais tous ne
sont pas bienvenus
soe gbagbo est un activiste politique au
liban depuis cinq ans il croit que des
gens comme lui ne pourront jamais
revenir chez eux
les activistes de la société civile nous
qui n'avons pas pris les armes vont
manifester nos pensées leur faisons peur
ils préfèrent ceux qui ont combattu
parce que ça sert leurs arguments de
lutte contre le terrorisme à propos du
régime que laisseront pas même s'ils
pouvaient rentrer soit bras qui ne
seraient jamais en sécurité chez lui
mollo
sous lui un sentiment exprimé dans ce
vidéoclip devenue virale sur les réseaux
sociaux
produit par des réfugiés syriens qui
vivent en turquie la chanson parodie
l'appel de la syrie à ses citoyens de
rentrer chez eux pour toutes les
promesses que peut leur faire le régime
ce n'est qu'un piège chante les jeunes
hommes un piège qui m'aidera beaucoup
d'entre eux en prison en proie à la
torture
[Musique]
officiellement les nations unies
considèrent que la situation sécuritaire
en syrie ne permet pas un retour des
réfugiés
le haut commissariat aux réfugiés agit
quand même à titre d'observateur à
chacun de ses départs se défendant
d'envoyer un message contradictoire
je crois que les besoins dans tous les
pays hôtes de la région demeurent les
mêmes dit elle
nous avons des millions de réfugiés à
l'extérieur de la syrie mais nous devons
appuyer ceux qui souhaitent rentrer à la
maison avec ou sans inquiétude à
l'esprit la fébrilité palpable de chez
les volontaires au retour leur fatigue
évidente
après des heures à attendre sous un
soleil de plomb des autobus
réquisitionnés pour le régime
il n'y a pas assez de place à bord pour
le peu de biens qu'ils possèdent cet
homme s'énerve et dit qu'il a changé
d'avis il ne veut plus partir
c'est finalement les soldats libanais
qui procureront un camion pour calmer la
crise et que les bagages soit du voyage
liste de présence comptage et
recomptages
il aura fallu plus de 11 heures pour
quelques on voit se met en route vers la
frontière
une journée épuisante angoissante mais
pour ces réfugiés
c'est devenu un quotidien un mode de vie
qu'ils espèrent maintenant laisser
derrière ici marie-eve bédard
radio-canada berry